[Music]
what's that right here yakety sax
somewhere god damn it
where's yakety sax coming from it's up
here oh it's the ghost of Benny Hill up
in the rafters it stopped for a
seriously yakety sax is playing up there
could you kill the that's I enjoyed that
let's kill that we got to get to the
real one it's right up there he's got
lower and it just went away I'm not
kidding
you break that you break it you don't
break that to physical no brothers he
didn't have brothers
he doesn't know look now he's gonna have
to do it to prove them wrong and then
break and then Woo's was somebody just
enjoying yakety sax
why was yakety sax playing climbing up
the charts at week number fourteen
thousand seven hundred and four will
address that matter I see nine emails
being written right now not meet sir I'm
playing a word game you're not the only
one with one of those devices sound
effect guy from police academy
[Music]